[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the distribution of wealth in
the wizarding world
we first get a glimpse of how wizarding
currency works in the philosopher's
stone when harry visits his vault
at gringotts bank hagrid brings him to
vault 687
and harry is suddenly faced with an
enormous pile of gold
all his harry had all of this money
because it was left to him
by his parents the potter family lineage
made their money in the potions business
starting with the founding patriarch of
the family linford of stinchco
it was a potion pioneer grincott's bank
is overlooked by goblins and they help
to control legislation
surrounding currency wizarding currency
consists of galleons
sickles and ganuts with galleons being
worth the most
and canada's being worth the least
wealth isn't mentioned or alluded to
much in harry potter
outside of instances which involve
either the weasleys or the male voice
the weasleys are known to be exceedingly
poor and inversely
the mouthways are exceedingly wealthy in
almost every exchange between a weasley
and a malfoy
wealth is mentioned condescendingly in
some capacity
when draco first meets ron he says the
following i think my name's funny do you
well no need to ask yours red hair and
hand me down robe
you must be a weasley and we later see
lucius make a similar sort of remark
let's see red hair vacant expressions
tatty second-hand book you must be the
weasleys
this suggests that there's certainly a
class system prevalent inside of the
wizarding world
and that the distribution of wealth like
our own world is not necessarily as even
as it should be
so this begs the question who is the
wealthiest
at first glance it really seems like the
answer may be the malfoy family
as their wealth is mentioned time after
time at the beginning of the deathly
hallows
the malfoy mansion hosts the death eater
meeting chaired by lord voldemort
when yaxi and snape approach the mansion
he actually snarls and notes there are
peacocks on the grounds
he murmurs with an edge of jealousy the
lucius malfoy always
did well their grand estate expensive
pets roaming the property
and mentions of wealth throughout the
books and films really seem to support
the argument that
they're the wealthiest the malfoys are
pure bloods with extensive wealth in
their lineage
and lucius holds a high position in the
ministry however i have reason to
believe
that they are only the second most
wealthy family
so who has the largest vault at
gringotts make him press his hand to the
door
griphook urged harry who turned his wand
again upon bogrod the old goblin obeyed
pressed his palm to the wood and the
door of the vault melted away to reveal
a cave-like opening
crammed from florida's ceiling with
golden coins and goblets
silver armor skins of strange creatures
some with long spines
others with drooping wings potions
injured and a skull
still wearing its crown the above
passage of course describes the entrance
to the vault of none other than
bellatrix lestrange
bellatrix the strange was a pure blood
witch that hailed from the black family
and later married into the pureblood le
strange family
both the black family and the strange
families were wealthy in their own right
both stemming from the sacred 28 a
directory of truly pure blood families
that still existed within the wizarding
world each family was immensely wealthy
with old money passing down from
generation to generation
bellatrix and her husband rodolfos ended
up with a large portion of the money
from both family trees and the
combination of these fortunes
made them the richest witch and wizard
the entire wizarding world
overshadowing even the malfoys yes
narcissa probably got some of the money
from the black family fortune as well
but given that bellatrix was a much more
overbearing personality
i would expect that she received a
larger share bellatrix was also the
older sister
bellatrix lived a lavish lifestyle and
there are a lot of reasons that she was
able to effectively hold on to her
fortune
first of all she spent a massive amount
of time in azkaban prison
which gave her almost no opportunity to
spend any of her huge fortune
it just sat there in the vault next
bellatrix didn't bear any children
at least until delfini who didn't appear
on our radar until long after bellatrix
died
which meant that she didn't have to
distribute the wealth within her family
at all
the malfoys had an impetuous and
expensive sun which no doubt took a
chunk out of their fortune
the lestrange vault at gringotts wasn't
just under high security because of the
horcrux hiding inside of it
it was also because it contained more
gold than any other vault in the
wizarding bank
bellatrix lestrange was the richest
witch in the entire wizarding world
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it what do you think
is this a compelling argument who do you
think is the richest
let us know down in the comment section
below until next time
your wizard hurry